[Music]
Dale is with us in Orlando hi Dale what
is your net worth little over three
million good for you and how is that
broken down the investment in that sir
Oh looks like a 1.6 in financial
management of financial investments for
50 elemental real estate mm-hmm
annuities around two hundred fifty six
thousand five hundred sixty thousand
mm-hmm I got a settlement coming from an
accent
I was totally around 250 thousand I got
a hundred and sixty thousand in cash
good for you well done how old are you
six at nine good for you and how much of
the three million is there because you
inherited it zero okay and what has what
was the range of your household income
while you were working from the most you
ever made to the least you ever made
most high place there may be a shoeshine
boy so yeah ten cents of the issues and
depends on how many people like a shoe
shows who and my team that was making
about probably say about nine or ten
thousand a year and my highest was in my
40s and that was in the military how
long were you in the military
fourteen years okay and you said to the
most you ever made was in the 40s yes
not your age 40s but $40,000 a year and
I was around 40 I guys that were made
this 48 FN 21 year late 51 were you
married yes sir
and did she work outside the home no sir
okay so you did all of this on 48
thousand dollars a year you know just
investing yeah you you've invested
very very aggressively for a long period
of time to get to these numbers very
well done very well done so good here
and bad yeah so you how many years did
you serve in the military again 14 yeah
yeah and which brand injured I was in
multiple services of the Army and Navy
okay thank you for your service
okay it was that your main career in
your working lifetime military or did
you have a different career that when I
was in college and I got drafted
mm-hmm and getting out on draft many
didn't well that they needed pops
helicopter pods bad they offer it to in
accepting diner service transfer and
stayed with them until I got disabled
okay okay cool I didn't mention that
that's part of my own co-founders
disability from military gotcha and what
was your degree in in college and then
say it again it was political science
overlying into military aeronautical
science okay alright good and what was
your GPA good at by around 2.8 2.9 okay
and how much of this 3 million dollar
net worth is there because you borrowed
money to create wealth 0 okay Wow
alright and what advice would you give
to the 25 year old version of you that
is listening out there can this still be
done and if you think it can how would
you tell them to do it just do a lot of
research it can't do it yourself
I'm people with the best people that can
do it for you okay cool
well thank you for joining us sir and
congratulations a three million dollar
net worth we appreciate you being with
us well done